et de
2700 qu à
6300 corps hier et aujourd'hui on
devrait avoir à peu près de 9000 quo
donc est vraiment une augmentation le
quai comme exponentielle et on pense des
spécialistes pensent qu'on va avoir un
impact sur les hospitalisations déjà
depuis une semaine on est passé de 309
hospitalisation à 445 et donc on pense
que dans les prochains jours il va y
avoir quand même une bonne augmentation
des hospitalisations c'est ça qui est
qui reste notre objectif le plus
important depuis le début donc ce qu'on
veut c'est que ça déborde pas dans les
hôpitaux qu'on soit capable de continuer
à soigner tout le monde s'assoit les
patients qu'aux vide où les patients que
je dérange kim est régulier et c'est
pour ça qu'on arrive avec des nouvelles
mesures aujourd'hui d'abord on demande à
tout le monde à partir de dimanche qui
vient donc à partir du 26 décembre
de limiter le nombre de personnes dans
les résidences privées à 6 ou deux
bulles de bulle familiale et on en la
même chose au restaurant a dit que à
chaque table dans les restaurants à
partir de dimanche ça sera au maximum
six personnes ou deux bulles donc deux
familles qui pourront seulement être là
ça veut dire que d'ici samedi on laisse
les gens qui veulent absolument se
rencontrer à 10 de le faire pas con
j'invite tous les québécois qui sont
capables de reporter ses failles de le
faire est aussi
encore long on vous le demande
d'avoir seulement un super une soirée
donc le 24 ou le 25 décembre par exemple
mais pas les deux fois mais et le plus
important c'est important que tout le
monde comprenne ça le plus important
ce sont les personnes de 60 ans et plus
haut qu'on regarde les chiffres
et puis on voit tout de suite
soixante dix pour cent des personnes qui
sont à l'hôpital pour la co lead 11,65
le soixante dix pour cent ça veut dire
que c'est vraiment ces personnes là qui
sont à risque
d'hospitalisation et
surtout les personnes qui n'ont pas
encore eu la chance d'avoir leur
troisième dose avec le var hier microns
sont vraiment à risque donc l'idéal
évidemment pour les personnes de 60 ans
et plus
je te demander d'enlever sa devant je
vois en vue de ce monde parfait
je voyais toutes sortes de textes
déroulé l'aube cesse sa main mélange et
donc je m'excuse je reviens donc aux
personnes de 60 ans le plus important
c'est vraiment les personnes de 60 ans
sont les plus vulnérables et lost une
question de jugement l'idéal évidemment
c'est de rester à la maison parce que je
le rappelle le 2
virus satrape juste en contact d'autres
personnes donc si vous restez chez vous
d'ailleurs aucun risque si vous tenez
absolument à
aller
dans une réunion familiale où une
réunion d'amis il faut que vous sachiez
qu'un risque d'abord si vous êtes prêts
à prendre ce risque là bas il ya quatre
façons de minimiser le risque
premièrement évidemment résumé le nombre
de personnes deuxièmement porter un
masque troisièmement garder une distance
de 2 mètres avec les autres personnes et
quatrièmement régulièrement ouvrait au
moins deux fenêtres dans la maison poe
aéré l'endroit donc si vous y tenez
vraiment les personnes de 60 ha mais je
le répète c'est là qu'on a soixante dix
pour cent des hospitalisations
évidemment ça veut pas dire que yo port
des risques chez les personnes de moins
de 60 ans il y en a quand même 30 % de
nos hospitalisation donc ces personnes
là aussi doivent faire des efforts puis
quand je demande de faire des efforts
c'est surtout pour le personnel soignant
ça fait 22 mois que nos travailleurs
travailleuses de la santé sont au front
évidemment beaucoup de gens fatigués
sont pas non plus exempts de l'attraper
le virus est important de dire là on
parlait du personnel soignant qui a
attrapé le virus la majorité et ils
l'ont attrapé et soin de leurs enfants
ou leurs amis comme tous les québécois
donc il faut effectivement est très très
très prudents tout le monde doit faire
sa part pour qu'on soit capable de
continuer à soigner tout le monde c'est
pour ça qu'on a pris des décisions du
depuis 22 mois je vous le rappelle le
québec a toujours été un des endroits au
monde
sûrement en amérique du nord où on a les
consignes les plus sévères puis
évidemment on le fait beaucoup et
d'abord pour le personnel de la santé
lucky vraiment
très taxée depuis 22 mois l'autre chose
qui est importante aussi salades une
évidence toi mais dès que vous avez des
symptômes c'est important de rester à la
maison
s'isoler maintenant pour ce qui est des
tests le docteur arruda je vais lui
donner la parole après
pour comprendre là dès qu'on soit des
tests rapides des autotests rapide du
gouvernement fédéral on les livre aux
pharmacies qui les lie évidemment on n'a
pas assez de tests rapides pour tout le
monde actuellement c'est pour ça qu'on
ne dit pour l'instant c'est important
que ces tests là soient réservés aux
personnes qui ont des symptômes
et puis c'est important aussi que les
personnes qui font la file pour aller
avoir un vrai test ce qu'on appelle un
test pcr mais aussi que ce soit les
personnes symptomatique prévue demain
vous allez comprendre qu'en passant de
2,3 milles qu à 9000 corps évidemment il
ya beaucoup plus de gens et hier ont eu
cinquante mille prélèvements on est
vraiment des niveaux record mais comme à
peu près partout le nombre de personnes
pour dépister est limité on veut aussi
accélérer la vaccination et les tests
rapides éventuellement on pense
j'entendais le premier du canada dire
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont nous en envoyer
d'autres dès qu'on va les recevoir on va
les envoyer dans les pharmacies et donc
éventuellement sapporo est une
précaution comprendre mais pour
l'instant c'est important que ce soit le
test rapide ou le test pcr de le faire
seulement si on a des symptômes bon ce
qui est important aussi je sais encore
là que des personnes qui sont allées
chercher une dose de doses piqueries
sont un peu tannique qui se disent est
ce que je dois vraiment aller chercher
la troisième dose oui il ya vraiment une
grosse différence de risque entre les
personnes qui ont deux grosses plaies
personnes qui ont trois doses donc faut
aller chercher sa troisième dose
actuellement les personnes de 65 ans et
plus peuvent le faire dès maintenant les
personnes de 60 à 64 ans vont pouvoir
commencer à prendre rendez-vous le dès
lundi qui vient le 27 décembre donc à
l'isi c'est important pour votre
précaution dont je parlais tantôt de la
vaccination
dès qu'on a eu le ok de la santé
publique d'augmenter la vitesse la
troisième dose stade et de réduire
l'intervalle entre la deuxième et la
troisième dose de 6 mois à 3 ans mort on
a beaucoup accéléré puis je dis merci à
tous ceux qui sont inscrits dans je
contribue à tous les médecins qui
viennent nous donner un coup de main on
ne réussit là à passer de 40000
vaccinations par jour à 88 milles
vaccinations par jour il ya donc ça
roule rondement et donc on pense que
évidemment au fur et à mesure qu'on va
donner la troisième dose ça va aider à
garder contrôle dans nos hôpitaux c'est
important de le dire le les mesures
qu'on annonce ce soir on pense que c'est
suffisant au regard des contrôles dans
les hôpitaux mais on va pas hésiter dans
les prochains jours si c'est nécessaire
d'ajouter des mesures de le faire donc
c'est important que tout le monde le
comprenne maintenant j'ai un message
pour les personnes qui sont pas fait
vacciner
d'abord peu importe que près lire ou
écouter c'est clair que vous vous mettez
beaucoup plus à risques de port être
vaccinés et vous mettez à risque aussi
nos hôpitaux je vous donne juste d'un
chiffre actuellement chez les adultes là
on a moins de 10 % des adultes qui sont
pas vaccinés meir présent
50% des personnes hospitalisées
si on n'avait pas les non vaccinés qui
sont même pas 10 % au québec on réduira
de moitié nos hospitalisation donc c'est
très grave puis peu importe la raison
pourquoi vous voulez pas aller vous
faire vacciner moujoud l'homme angles si
vous le faites pas pour vous faites vous
faites le pour les autres mais rester à
la maison parce que ya un risque un plus
grand risque que vous vous retrouviez à
l'hôpital que vous vient et que vous
veniez engorgé nos hôpitaux puis
empêcher peut-être éventuellement pour
un sou est paul des personnes de pouvoir
soit de recevoir des soins urgents puis
évidemment on va vous parler un peu de
délestage donc les non vaccinés là je
vous le demande
pour le québec pour les eaux rester s'il
vous plaît chez vous si vous voulez pas
vous faire vacciner dont un mot peau
ceux qui vont qui ont travaillé depuis
22 mois qui vont travailler pendant le
temps des fêtes dans le réseau de la
santé évidemment lors on vous remerciera
jamais assez
je sais que c'était dur mais tout le
québec compte sur vous on a besoin de
vous autres les prochaines semaines vont
un critique est important d'avoir tout
le personnel qu'on est capable d'avoir
ce soit des médecins des infirmières
tous les travailleurs de la santé ben
c'est important là pour passer au
travers que vous fassiez encore un
effort pujol c'est qu'on vous en a déjà
demandé beaucoup donc en terminant
je veux dire aux québécois
on parle plus on va passer dans les
prochaines semaines une très dure
épreuve mais c'est pas la première fois
que notre peuple fait face à une grande
épreuve et on a toujours réussi à serrer
les coudes et être capable d'avoir une
grande cohésion sociale entre nous ben
je suis confiant à cause de ça qu'on va
est capable comme peuple de passer au
travers cette grande épreuve mais dans
les prochains jours on va avoir besoin
les uns des autres passera par un bon
noël pour tout le monde donc c'est
important d'aider les autres appelé les
personnes qui sont seules et prenez soin
les uns des autres
je compte sur vous merci beaucoup
sur ce je passe la parole au docteur à
godard qui va vous parler des tests de
dépistage
merci monsieur le premier ministre c'est
le ministre
je voulais prendre un instant pour
revenir sur le dépistage et
l'utilisation des tests de dépistage
rapide à la maison je viens vous dire
que demain va y avoir un briefing
technique aussi là où les journalistes
ont été invités pour pouvoir poser
toutes leurs questions sur les
différentes situations il ya toutes
sortes une série d'infographies qui va
être rendu disponible pour la population
là pour qu'ils sachent quoi faire comme
tel vous savez on connaît quasiment tous
actuellement quelqu'un qui a très peu la
copie d'une photo de nous donc un
vraiment un nombre de cas qui augmente
de façon exponentielle
depuis quelques jours et ça nous a
amenés à revoir notre stratégie de de
dépistage les capacités de dépistage au
québec ont quand même grandement évolué
on se souvient qu'en septembre 20 20 on
avait un jour environ 15000 ites de
possibles par jour actuellement notre
capacité et autour de 50 mille tests par
jour mais actuellement avec la quantité
de coquio on doit avoir une certaine
approche qui va permettre d'utiliser de
façon la plus efficiente possible aux
tests
on était en pleine capacité des joueurs
actuellement comme je le disais puis
dans ce contexte les tests de
laboratoire devrait être réservée aux
personnes comme le disait premier
ministre en taux qui ont des symptômes
qui s'apparentent à la coved 19 ça c'est
de la fièvre date ou un mal de gorge ou
une perte de goût et de l'odorat donc
dorénavant il faut vraiment se présenter
dans les cliniques de dépistage si vous
êtes dans l'une ou l'autre des
catégories suivantes
si vous présentez des symptômes et que
vous n'avez pas de tests rapides à la
maison
vous prenez un rendez-vous comme tête
vous vous isolez vous prenez rendez vous
pour pouvoir vous faire dépister si vous
avez des symptômes et que vous passez un
test rapide à la maison et que le
résultat est positif
vous vous isolez que vous pouvez aller
passer un test dans un centre de
dépistage pour confirmer si c'est
accessible pour vous comme tel mais vous
pouvez aussi seulement vous fier sur le
test rapide et rester à la maison pour
éviter la transmission donc vous vous
isolez s'ils avaient été en contact avec
quelqu'un qui a la coved 19 on vous
demande de vous isoler pendant dix jours
et vous présenter dans une clinique de
dépistage uniquement si vous développez
des symptômes de la coved 19 vous
surveiller l'apparition des symptômes
d'abord et en côte symptômes vous vous
présenterez dans une clinique de
dépistage à nouveau il est fortement
recommandé de prendre rendez vous afin
de limiter les risques de transmission
aux autres est actuellement aussi
d'éviter de se retrouver dans des fils
parce qu'avec au rendez vous on va avoir
plus de fluidité
cette nouvelle orientation va permettre
de prioriser les personnes qui sont les
plus susceptibles d'être positive à la
comédie neige et d'accélérer le
processus pour tous d'ailleurs
dorénavant les résultats de tests de
dépistages positifs vont vous être
communiqué par courriel à tous ceux qui
l'auront consentis les personnes non
infectées auront plus rapidement une
confirmation est doué pourrons à ce
moment là informé plus rapidement leurs
contextes significatif vous comprenez qu
avec une plus de 2000 cas les équipes de
santé publique ne peuvent plus retracer
tous les cas et les contacts donc on
vous demande si vous avez était
symptomatique avec un test positif
la collaboration de tous pour aviser les
personnes avec qui vous avez été en
contact depuis l'apparition des premiers
symptômes et rapidement je suis sur le
fait qu'il est préférable d'utiliser les
autotests à bon escient soit pour les
personnes qui présentent des symptômes
c'est pas utile actuellement de
gaspiller un test juste pour vérifier
son fonctionnement
j'aimerais maintenant aussi peut-être
vous parlez de l'importante chose une
des choses les plus importantes que la
vaccine a sion et la fameuse dose de
rappel il faut comprendre qu'on ait une
accélération de la dose de rappel va se
faire au cours des prochaines semaines
on a déjà vu au cours des derniers jours
une accélération importante selon les
arrivages les personnes se verront
offrir le vaccin de pfizer ou moderna je
rappelle que ce sont deux vaccins à arn
messager ils ont fonctionnement une
composition semblables ils sont
considérés comme interchangeables
recevoir avec saint différent de ce
qu'on a reçu la première ou la deuxième
dose est sécuritaire donc vous pouvez
avoir aussi un phaser un phaser on vous
donne un moderna c'est tout à fait
correct les livraisons de file seront
sans doute limité au cours des
prochaines semaines mais si on vous
offre un vaccin mort d'anna n'hésitez
pas surtout allez le prendre dans le
contexte actuel la dose de rappel va
vous protéger vous qu énormément de
circulation et on va tout faire pour
accélérer l'accès au rendez-vous
quand terminant également je voudrais
faire un appel au sens civique dans les
derniers jours des incidents se sont
produits dans les cliniques de dépistage
août vaccination et à eau près nos
pharmacies on comprend le stress on
comprend l'inquiétude mais il faut
rester civiliser les avec les autres ont
contraint que la saison peut représenter
un stress pour plusieurs mais le
personnel est là pour nous aider et on
doit être traité avec respect et
courtoisie finalement jeunes a ajouté
löw si vous permettez
je pense que vous voyez là chaque foyer
de la circulation actuellement de kobe
de 19 je pense que plus on se rend
compte plus on sort de nos bulles connu
plus on s'expose à un risque et donc si
vous pouvez diminuer vos contacts même
dans le temps des fêtes de noël il est
prochain souper le jeu vous invite
fortement à le faire de ne garder que
les éléments les plus essentiels
pour reprendre les mots du docteur
arruda sion gare de sébastien beauvais
ce qu'est de plus essentiel dans le
point de presse ça se résume assez
rapidement finalement pour noël on
change rien on demande aux gens de
reporter si possible bien sûr d'être le
plus prudent possible on demande aux non
vaccinés de rester à la maison mais
c'est à partir du dimanche comme vous le
disiez sébastien que l'on dit 6 ou deux
bulles n'y pas de jour de l'an à dire
soit 15
on verra quelle est l'explication de
françois legault et de reçus à ruda pour
permettre quelque chose le 24 25 et
réduire les rassemblements à partir du
26 qu'est-ce qu'il ya des différentes en
48 heures probablement que la réponse
sera une question de santé mentale de
permettent donc aux gens de se
rassembler mais essentiellement le
gouvernement est conséquent avec
lui-même dans son message en disant oui
vous allez pouvoir avoir semblé mais
dans la mesure du possible éviter de
multiplier les contacts éviter de
multiplier les soupers éviter de
multiplier les rassemblements on vous
donne des balises mais gérez-vous selon
le degré de risque que vous êtes capable
de prendre et faites attention aux
personnes de plus de 60 michel et
stéphanie je me fais l'avocat didia mais
tous avaient été dit pas mal
longuement il expliqué dans les autre
point de presse qu il vraiment nouveau
brut nouveau c'est le six personnes à
compter de dimanche michel c'est pas un
détail mais disons qu'il n'ya pas de
révolution
mais pas de révolution il n'y a pas
d'appel le gouvernement ne voit pas de
raison d'en faire une non plus
monsieur vous malgré tout à l'air de
dire on va être capable de passer au
travers d'un des hôpitaux si on on suit
les consignes et qu'on n'y a pas d'effet
relance du nouveau variant mais si on
suit les consignes comme on limite
la peine finalement c'est à dire on ne
vous dit pas d'aller se faire de jour
d'honneur cette année et d'autre part si
vous faites de schreibers fait ça dont
je sois c'est ça le message le port pour
ce qui est des rassemblements familiaux
on verra je sais quel point elle se
soient écoutés mais je pense qu il y
était difficile aussi
été à ce point critique on ne peut pas
on va écouter la prédication convient
ensemble a tout de suite
une question une suggestion par
journalistes au micro un ami qui met que
j'ai couvert bonsoir à vous tous vous
évoquez le 9000 cas par jour on dirait
que le délestage est au coin de la rue
on va faire ça comment est-ce qu'on va
profiter des entre guillemets fermeture
du temps des fêtes pour prolonger on va
prendre ce par quel bout
j'ai commencé premièrement on va essayer
de minimiser le délestage le plus
possible sur place pour rassurer les
gens mais avec le nom de pop on a ces
jours ci
la grande inconnue selon vous dire c'est
qu'elle est le taux de sévérité de
micron
vous allez voir dans les simulations qui
ont été faites par nos experts c'est la
plus grande variable c'est la plus
grande inconnue que l'on a à ce moment
de savoir est-ce qu'on va avoir le même
impact sur l'hospitalisation plus grand
au plus petit on souhaite tous que ça
soit plus petit on a eu des veilles
internationale dans les derniers jours
de nos experts nous ont montré que dans
certains pays où le taux de vaccination
est comparable avec la nôtre le nombre
d'hospitalisations et la longueur
pouvait hype plus intéressante mais
encore une fois faut prévoir tous les
scénarios comme le dit le premier
ministre en ce moment on pense qu'avec
la situation actuelle est la marge de
manoeuvre qu'on s'est donné docteur au
patin et son équipe ont préparé au score
être capable de passer de la trop de
nouveau trois au niveau 4 de délestage
et si on pense que pour le moment c'est
suffisant si jamais on a besoin de faire
plus on fera plus mais c'est ça qu'on
suit et c'est pour ça qu'on est très
transparent dans les données notamment
de l'inesss qui ont été publiés
aujourd'hui ne sait pas qu'elle a eue en
sortie exactement mais c'est ça qui
aurait pu l'être le plus grandes
variables dans les prochains jours à
suivre
vous avez parlé du traçage est ce qu'on
doit comprendre que on a pu les moyens
d'en faire que c'est devenu trop
compliqué et qu'on remet
dans les mains des personnes contaminées
la responsabilité d'appeler leurs
contacts seulement peut-être commencer
là dessus puis de travers ou d'heures
compléteront
la raison pour laquelle on a là
premièrement on vous l'avait bien dit on
est tous cas pas de faire le traçage de
la même façon qu'on faisait avant puis
on a vu le depuis quelques semaines
particulièrement avec montréal docteur
drew ont montré que les effectifs
étaient peut-être mieux placés ailleurs
et comme on a beaucoup de monde qui est
d'un traçage plus qu'en ce moment on est
rendu à presque 80 % 2 microns je pense
que nous le personnel serait pas tenue à
la vaccination alors c'est ça qu'on est
en train ter parce qu'on se dit quand on
est rendu à 80 ou 90 pour ça je pense
qu'on sait qu'on va avoir les pieds au
nom de 1000 cas et c'est pour ce qu'on
demande aux gens puis je vais laisser le
docteur ou de compléter mais on demande
aux gens quand on les appelle de dire
s'il vous plaît informé ce que vous avez
vu dans les dernières heures ou derniers
jours informés les vous mêmes nous ça
nous permet de re replacer le personnel
ailleurs dans des notamment dans la
vaccination
on savait qu'on allait en arriver à ça
il faut comprendre qu'on s'en vont aussi
de plus en plus un nouveau paradigme
d'autogestion la maladie puis moment
donné quand invariants comme le au
micron qui est excessivement
transmissibles de par le temps que vous
la personne et des symptômes que quel
prochain test qu'on reçoive le résultat
elle déjà contaminé toute une série de
personnes et donc on n'a pas la même
efficacité pour empêcher ou contenir la
transmission et à ce moment là on pense
beaucoup plus faire des mesures
d'autogestion d'auto enseignement et
d'auto prise en charge ainsi que je
voudrais ajouter des tests de dépistage
qui vont s'associer c'était déjà prévu
cette tension là on savait qu'on allait
arriver à ça les ans je sais qu'avec le
au micro on y arrive encore plus vite
comme tels parce que ces énergies ne
sont pas efficaces on et me déplacer là
où on va avoir des gains notamment c'est
ce que de certains milieux certaines
éclosion qui vont être encore regarder
ça sert à rien la situation le virus est
beaucoup trop plus rapide que ce qu'on
est capable de faire en termes de
traçage
oui bonjour ou trois peut-être ensuite
il assume ses rondeurs
au sujet du dépistage vous parlé
d'autogestion messi s'il ya des jeunes
afin qu'ils se plient pas vous nouvelle
directive est ce qu'on va envisager des
mesures plus fortes et ce qu'on pourrait
aller juste pour moi modéré l'accès aux
centres en fonction de la situation de
chacun enfin dans le slip il ne diminue
pas avec les nouvelles victimes que vous
donnez qu'est-ce qu'on va fanfaronner
[Musique]
on al'impression qu'avec je demande aux
gens seulement symptomatique de venir se
présenter on va diminuer la pression
déjà d'une bonne proportion des gens qui
font des tests exxon le des gens
symptomatique actuellement qui font des
tests juste parce qu'ils veulent à
l'emporter ou d'autre chose on le tourne
en eau de son sursis pour une bonne
utilisation
ça sert pas la personne ne passera peut
être aussi dangereuses et que c'est un
convoi a baissé cela mais vous
comprendrez que tout comme nouveau faire
c'est on va s'ajuster en fonction des
indicateurs comme le dit notre premier
ministre si on se rend compte qu'on est
en train de perdre le contrôle on va
être obligé d'ajouter des mesures
supplémentaires et c'est pour ça que
j'ai vite les québécois pour nous éviter
d'aller à des mesures supplémentaires ou
beaucoup plus de rester comme on a déjà
connu de diminuer leurs contacts le
temps qu'on passe à travers ce d'éclat
puis qu'on ne met pas en péril notre
système de son donc je pense que chacun
maintenant tu veux puisque toujours des
personnes qui ne respecteront pas mais
la meilleure chose qu'on peut faire
c'est de faire donne une troisième
d'auge pour 520 kg et de diminuer nos
contacts et d'utiliser la distanciation
le port du masque
en ce résultat est une question sur la
santé mentale vous le savez des oiseaux
qui vous annoncent aujourd'hui les
maisons examen dans ces 10 derniers
jours ça crée beaucoup de stress sacré
d'isolement donc ma question c'est ça va
être quoi les quelles mesures concrètes
tout accès non plus mettre en place pour
soutenir les québécois sur le plan
psychologique au delà par exemple le
temps ou encore de te dire comme l'avait
dit mme sur le goût de prendre soin les
uns des autres c'est quoi les mesures
concrètes qu'on peut remettre de votre
côté même mon collègue lionel carmant à
augmenter des ressources notamment
téléphonique par le limiteur on est
capable de répondre très rapidement dont
je sais que beaucoup de gens qu'on
appelle qui appelle brésard main mais on
a mis tout en place pour être capable de
donner le service le plus rapide à ceux
à ce qu'ils appellent en ce moment et
deuxième match parce qu'on est on est
conscient puisque est le premier
ministre dit prenons conscience de de
ceux qui sont seuls puis juste de les
appeler des gens sont inquiets on le
comprend mais on voit la fin de son
voilà on voit cette fin là il s'agit
juste de rester forts avec eux qui ce
conseil qui ont un certain doute de les
appeler nous mêmes mais pour ne pas en
augmenter la capacité de services
téléphoniques
les prochaines questions
à
marie provost le devoir ce la tendance
se maintient la capacité
d'hospitalisation votre attaque quand
même très vite au québec ce que vous
avez une marge de manoeuvre pour ajouter
des lits supplémentaires puis si oui
dans quel délai
vianney mais c'est ce que j'ai voulu
expliquer tout à l'heure c'est que à ce
moment vous vous le suivez on donne la
sts est ce que tous les jours on a une
capacité de nos inscrits alisation plus
les soins intensifs d'un petit peu plus
que huit ça avec les statistiques qui
vont en sortir demain on va être un
petit peu plus haut au dessus de 55 % de
7 alors donc on a déjà encore de la
marge de manoeuvre puis on n'a pas vu
les bénéfices du délestage si je peux le
dire comme ceux additionnel qui est en
train de se préparer donc on a encore de
la marge de manoeuvre l'enjeu puis je
voudrais expliquer pour tout le monde le
comprenne bien c'est qu'on ne sait pas
en ce moment deux degrés de sévérité de
migrants parce que la plupart des jacks
sont à l'hôpital aujourd'hui non au
moment où je vous parle quand je vous
dis qu'on à 55% de notre capacité
hospitalière
c'est principalement du delta on n'a pas
vu encore les faits au micro ça va parce
qu'on est toujours tributaire de 5 7 8
jours de ce qui s'est passé on n'avait
pas encore cet effet au micron là qui
est avec nous m alors comme je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure et c'est ça qu'on suit
avec le docteur roberto nous on va
regarder comment se fait c'est quoi le
délai d'un spécialisation et c'est pour
ce qu'on suit avec nos expériences qui
se passe en europe qui est en avance sur
nous ils ont à peu près dix jours
d'expérience en ce moment pour regarder
la longueur des hospitalisations de
degré de sévérité
au besoin on va s'ajuster mais je vous
dis en ce moment on a de la marge de
manoeuvre c'est sûr qu'on voit s ces
séries dépendamment des scénarios qu'on
fait mais on voit agir pour sauvegarder
cette marge de manoeuvre
sinon au niveau de la vaccination il
convient de vaccinateurs qui manque pour
l'instant parce que l'ajout de nouvelles
de nouvelles forces vives est suffisant
pour passe à travers le temps des fêtes
je dis souvent que c'est important de
donner les bonnes nouvelles on eu plus
de 8000 personnes qui ont rappelé à je
contribue depuis une semaine c'est
extraordinaire je veux en profiter pour
remercier tout le monde c'est sûr que à
l'intérieur de ça il ya nombre de
vaccinateurs dont on avait besoin mais
je continue de dire que étant donné
qu'on va voir un groupe d'une
vaccination en janvier-février non non
on a un autre 6 millions de personnes à
repasser en troisième dose déjà qui
encore aujourd'hui voudraient lever la
main pour vacciner on veut l'épreuve
alors soyons clairs le malgré le nombre
important qu'on ait eu
notre plus gros enjeux et dans la
prochaine semaine ou dix jours parce que
dans le temps des fêtes demain les gens
veulent sont peut-être moins existé à
venir nous aider pour les comprend j'en
profite pour remercier beaucoup les
médecins les médecins ont levé la main
depuis quelques jours particulièrement
les gens de la fmsq de nos spécialistes
impôts plus tard que c'était un vrai
meeting confirmé que 250 médecins qui
vont vacciner dans les prochains jours
donc l'enjeu pour nous c'est d'avoir
tout ce qu'il faut pour être capable de
vacciner massivement
à partir du 1er janvier lorsqu'on aura
complété
notre personnel de la santé qu'on est en
train de faire ça c'est notre plus
grande priorité parce que c'est ces gens
là qu'on veut pas en plus qui tombe
malade lorsque ces 2 e qu'on a besoin en
ce moment nos personnes vulnérables
on a presque complété nonou rpa donc
pour répondre à votre question à ce
moment là l'enjeu des vignes
vaccinateurs n'y plus un enjeu c'est
plus de s'assurer de la logistique pour
le faire à partir du début de janvier et
regardez aujourd'hui la d'être capable
d'avoir fait 88 mais c'est déjà on est
déjà proche de notre objectif de 100
milles par jour donc de ce côté là ça va
bien on va continuer merci prochain
journaliste aura tous thomas gerber de
radio canada vous l'avez dit les adultes
c'est 50 les adultes non vaccinés ces 50
% des lits d'hospitalisation dédié à la
preuve est qu'ils occupent alors qu'ils
sont que 10% de la population mais ces
gens là vous n'avez pas voulu être plus
dur avec eux en leur imposant la
vaccination obligatoire
on va nous imposer la fermeture au
cinéma ou salles de spectacles qui ont
très peu d'éclosion vous imposer des
restrictions à des québécois qui ont
suivi vos demandes qui ont reçu leur
dose heures trois doses elle vous
imposer des mesures semblables aux plus
vulnérables aux plus jeunes qui sont pas
très malade sauf rares exceptions alors
pourquoi par exemple ne pas confiné
uniquement les plus vulnérables ils le
sont déjà et puis pourquoi ne pas
imposer la vaccination obligatoire
je m'écoutais je pense qu'elle aime je
dirais simplement aujourd'hui que s'il
faut aller là on ira là en ce moment
n'est pas là
j'aimerais ça ou si dire quand on a fait
beaucoup
les québécois ont fait énormément du
côté de la vaccination ce que je pense
qu'il faut respecter aussi de tout ce
qui a été fait par les québécois
maintenant si on avait besoin d'aller
plus loin puisque c'est ce qu'on ne
discute et on le fera mais aujourd'hui
dans les circonstances on est capable de
passer à travers mais j'aimerais vous
rappeler monsieur géré bec dans les
dernières semaines dans les derniers
mois les québécois qui se sont fait
vacciner ont été capables de trouver un
semblant de normalité ce qui n'est pas
le cas des non vaccinés des non vaccinés
on exulte passeport ou d'accident on a
fait beaucoup pour faire une grande
différence entre les vaccinés et donne
envie mais je le répète s'il faut aller
plus loin dans les interdictions aux non
vaccinés étant donné que la situation
pourrait encore se détériorer
on hésite europe enfin
monsieur legault au printemps 2001 vous
aviez fait preuve de transparence nous
aviez présenté d état de stocks de
matériel médical avec le nombre de jours
qui nous restent et là on entend vaccin
file on en aura peut-être pas autant
qu'on voulait les tests alors j'aimerais
savoir les vaccins files oui nous en
reste pour combien de jours
les tests pcr les tests rapides on en a
pour combien de jours les médicaments
pour soigner les patients en soins
intensifs qu'ovide on en a pour combien
de jours et puis les masques n95 est ce
qu'on en a assez pour les donner à tous
les travailleurs de la santé bon écoute
et vous avez plusieurs questions je
pense que je vais je vais vous dire
premièrement on va être transparent très
transparent au niveau de hauts niveaux
de file la bonne nouvelle c'est que on
est en discussion avec le fédéral
avec puis j'en ai reparlé avec daniel
paris pas plus tard que ce matin on a ce
qu'il faut pour sectionner la bonne
nouvelle c'est pour ça que le docteur
arruda rassurer tout le monde si jamais
on avait ont manqué dans les prochaines
semaines les pratiques c'est sûr mais on
a quand même énormément de flexibilité
avec modern au
total de modernité de father fait que au
maquereau pas de vaccin on a demandé à
nous à nos homologues fédéraux de nous
assurer que le plus rapidement pensé on
va avoir d'autres mesures qui vont nous
arriver mais je pense que je veux
rassurer les québécois ont macro pas de
vaccin à la et même en augmentant la
capacité que l'on fait maintenant sur le
reste du matériel dont vous vous mordez
c'est la même chose c'est sûr que on va
être capable de d'avoir les noms de
matériel qu'on veut du ce que je dirais
je vous dirai ma grande préoccupation en
ce moment c'est d'abord le plus de tests
rapides du fédéral si j'avais quelque
chose on à votre question on en attend
encore cinq cent mille 100 semaines ces
120 minutes qu'on l'y rejoint qu'on les
reçoit pardon on va les mettre en
pharmacie vous le voyez la demande des
québécois pour pour les tests rapides
alors à ce moment là on va continuer à
travailler très fort fédéral pour qu'ils
augmentent la livraison de du test
rapide puisse dire et même on est en
train de considérer d'autres
alternatives pour être sûr qu'on a le
plus été frappé de possibles et donc je
veux être très clair monsieur gerbail il
n'ya pas d'un jeu actuellement nous y
manque d'équipement quelque soit ce qui
nous manque c'est des tests répit depuis
monsieur trudeau annonce aujourd'hui
deux funds en envoyer plus donc pas
dangereux depuis le début on a été
transparents 6 à 20 ans je oui manque
d'équipement voilà je dirais aux
québécois donc j'ai été complètement
transparent monsieur gervais depuis le
début je continuais de l'est est-ce que
je peux rajouter le premier ministre je
veux en profiter dans nos pharmaciens
font un travail extraordinaire pour ce
tout à l'heure contre dr arruda parler
aux gens de je sais que c'est pas facile
en ce moment on aimerait en avoir plus
de tests rapides leur mini pharmaciens
font un boulot extraordinaire
ils viennent de fans de finir l'influent
raso y ont pensé aux tests rapides ils
nous aident dans la vaccination
plus de 5000 vaccins qui ont été donnés
par des pharmaciens hier à tout de suite
après avoir laisser d'influx à georges
de laisser durer parce qu'il nous donne
un moyen coup de main en ce moment
durant une période où on n'est plus de
mise en avoir des vaccinateurs alors
j'apprécie beaucoup le travail qu'ils
ont fait nous allons
maintenant poursuivre pendant pendant
jeu nous allons renforcer avec nos
journalistes francophones via la
plateforme web en débutant par quelque
chose' quotidien de
bond 23
je continue sur matériel
protégé
personnel hospitalier
qu'est ce qu'on fait là pour
[Musique]
écouter sur le jeu je vous dirai pas
autant pour les milieux de vie ce qu'on
appelle nos milieux de vie a trop et
nono ch et celle des noirs pernaut nos
ressources intermédiaires on suit la
situation de très très proche parce que
où on a besoin de s'assurer puis je veux
rassurer tout le monde est important
on n'est pas du tout à dans le niveau où
on était à la première vague malgré
l'augmentation des coûts et lorsqu'on a
des cas on est encore très transparent
on envoie des équipes pour s'assurer
qu'on a tout la bonne information parce
que vous rappelez vous de la première
vague ce qui nous manquait c'était de
l'information et non à cette information
dont dany milieu de vie et pendant jeu
du côté des hôpitaux donc des milieux de
soins on a eu des éclosions aussi minime
c'est pour ça malheureusement qu'on a dû
restreindre des visiteurs on a des
limites et des visiteurs au projet d'un
parce que l'enjeu ne vient pas de
l'intérieur l'enjeu vient qu'une
contamination communautaire qui est
amenée par les gens qui la trappe et qui
malheureusement
je le dis là j'ai beaucoup d'empathie
pour déjà qu'ils nous disent pourquoi je
peux pas départ mais mes parents ou à
l'hôpital mais écoutez vous voyez la
vitesse à laquelle se répandent de virus
donc il a fallu limiter des entrées dans
les hôpitaux
[Musique]
on devrait
les stages alors on en est
qu'est ce que vous dites aux québécois
qui sont
soit reporté
alors ceci
je vous réponds de ce qu'on essaye de
minimiser le psy d'ailleurs pour ça que
je parlais encore docteur aux patines et
pio au pdg cet après midi ce qu'il faut
éviter pour nous c'est de délester des
opérations continues et aucun délestage
de d'opérations qui s'en dit urgente ce
qu'il faut être capable de voir c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on peut reporter il n'y a
jamais rien d'agréable à reporter des
opérations même non urgentes mais ces
deux là dessus quand
on se fixe des objectifs d'essayer de
minimiser le délestage mais il ya des
québécois au cours des prochains jours
prochaines semaines qui vont se faire
rappeler pour retarder des chirurgies je
veux être très transparent avec les gens
en ce moment il faut mettre l'effort sur
la vaccination pour protéger nos 60 ans
et plus et c'est sûr qu'on travaille en
ce moment
la parole à monsieur
journal de québec journal de montréal
bonsoir messieurs le concernant le choix
que vous faites de limiter les
rassemblements à partir du 26 décembre
seulement c'est le troisième - parce que
vous organisez en moins d'une semaine
ont resserré les mesures une situation
qui évolue et extrêmement rapidement
dans lequel il ya beaucoup
d'éléments incertain notamment
[Musique]
au micro est-ce qu'on a répondu
immédiatement réduire plus possible et
compte à convaincre les québécois de ne
pas sortir qu'est-ce qui a fait pencher
la balance
dans ce cas ci il ya deux choses
premièrement on a bougé beaucoup depuis
hier depuis une semaine on est passé de
20 à 10 et l'on passe à 6 alors mais
oublions des chiffres ont de 10 ou
clairement aux québécois aussi
c'est un bâtiment puis qu'il fallait se
fier au jugement déjà il faut aussi
comprendre que les québécois vaccinés
les jonctions fait vacciner quand fait
tous les sacrifices
on doit avoir un peu de bonheur dans les
prochains jours est ce parce que pour
moi la dezir sociale quand on en a parlé
avec le premier ministre c'est vraiment
important alors les québécois ils sont
responsables la grande majorité des
québécois ont été excessivement
responsable et c'est ce qu'on pense
qu'on fait au cours des prochains jours
mais je le dis le premier ministre dit
après le 26 il y aura peut-être d'autres
décisions qui seront prises mais en ce
moment essayons de fêter un bon noël
avec un angle plus restreint possible
étant donné des circonstances
donc
annoncer des mesures qui entrent en
vigueur le 26 décembre il est faux de
date de la fin pour ces mesures là est
ce que c est capable de donner
un indicatif à partir duquel on sort de
ce décès
écoutez je pense que là vous apprécie
beaucoup votre question mais je vais
vous répondre qu'en ce moment c'est pas
pour être très très transparent par
contre ce que vous pouvez suivre avec
nous c'est à quelle mesure les québécois
vont respecter les conditions au cours
des prochains jours de ce qu'il faut
voir c'est comment évolue la situation
dans nos hôpitaux on était très
transparent vous avez toutes les
statistiques pour de suivre avec nous
j'aimerais ça qu'on voit malgré la
hausse des cas comme on est capable de
contrôler nos hôpitaux alors l'effort
qu'on demande aux québécois en ce moment
c'est de limiter le nombre de contacts
avec les mesures d'hier celle
d'avant-hier par dont celle
d'aujourd'hui on pense qu'on peut
baisser le nombre de contacts de façon
importante on espère que ça va être
suffisant et c'est ce qu'on demande aux
québécois de baisser le plus possible le
nombre de contacts
maintenant au tour des membres à nouveau
oui bonjour monsieur je veux savoir si
vous avez envisagé ou vous envisagez
toujours leur taux aux hommes de couleur
le parce qu'il ya encore des disparités
régionales demandant le nombre de cas
alors qu'est ce qu'un passé le 26 c'est
encore une option c'est de limiter les
déplacements inter régionaux au québec
pour le moment non parce que je pense
que la situation est tellement critique
dans l'ensemble de la québec je pense
que le jeu vous allez trouver que je me
répète ou que je radote on faut que ce
tellement sur la vaccination à ce moment
que je voudrais qu'on soit capables d'à
mais peut-être que dans gouda vous
pouvez compléter la tuer mais je pense
que des choses qu'il faut retenir c'est
dit mulet contact jeu sur les
déplacements états régionaux surtout
chambonas une zone dans une vie coule
pas de trop de coqs seulement là c'est
plus risqué d'avoir des contrôles dans
les avions etc
dans le fond on peut pas dire que quand
elles savent arrêté est ce qu'on va
revenir à des pays rouges est-ce qu'on
veut revenir à des mesures défensives
ça vaut tellement rapidement partout
bayard qu'on a mis à avoir une approche
paramétrique mais l'avenir on sait pas
de quoi il va être fait et donc je vous
dirais je ne vous dirai pas jamais
jamais mais je pense que pour le moment
ça s'étale tellement rapidement vous
vivez vous cet été dans le monde d'une
façon dramatique
heureusement ça monte ça finit par
descendre mais c'est cette grande côte
là la montée par des sangles faut être
prudent c'est là que ça va prendre
encore de l'énergie
merci le premier ministre on en est où
dans les demandes qui ont été faites par
exemple
venant fédéral pour l'aide de l'armée
canadienne et aussi auprès de la croix
rouge checa des discussions depuis
quelques jours mais on en est où dans
ces discussions le présent on a eu un ok
d'accroire ou jeu mais on ne peut pas
encore le nombre de personnes qui pour
ce qui est de l'armée au menu l'on
parlerait de quelques dizaines de
personnes donc
on s'organise le st l'armée
merci gabriel wallet le tsar
communication oui mon sens mes sujets
très suivie sur la question de mon
collègue monsieur bourassa quand on
compare les données des plus récente
hospitalisation accident dû à la colle
et de 19 à région on se rend compte que
certaines régions comme montréal par
exemple sont beaucoup plus difficiles
que d'autres
nationale contenue culte et la grande
disparité dans les capacités
hospitalières et l'accès aux vaccinale
d'une région à l'autre ce faire pourquoi
ne pas envisager de revenir à un système
régional des amis d'el
milia plusieurs composantes à votre
votre question je commençais par la
disparité
régional de vaccination c'est sûr que
des régions comme montréal comme
l'estrie comme la montérégie qui sont
qui ont un taux de positivité qui
beaucoup plus élevé puis son peu de
passes et plus vous avez des régions qui
sont denses en terme de population avec
le taux de positivité est plus élevé
donc en ce moment et vous allez voir que
je me répète et c'est pour ça qu'en ce
moment notre faut que c'est sur la
vaccination la moyenne la moyenne du
taux de positivité qu'on avait le en
date d'hier est à peu près petit peu en
mode 15% 14.8 je crois et peut monter en
estrie jusqu'à 21 22% c'est pour vous
montrer la différence donc
avant de regarder du côté des hôpitaux
je pense que tu important depuis
clarifier le taux de positivité
maintenant sur les hôpitaux jusqu'à
maintenant il est peut-être le streak
est un peu plus serré que les autres et
on a fait en estrie des déplacements
vers d'autres régions at route vers la
mauricie centre du québec pour être
capable de pallier lorsque on se
rapprochait trop de notes zone maximum
mais encore une fois la meilleure façon
d'éviter des surcharges dans certaines
régions au niveau des hospitalisations
c'est de suivre très près la vaccination
on saura ce moment daniel paris de son
équipe font un boulot fantastique
alors voilà l'essentiel de
ce qui se résume assez facilement
sébastien michel stefani six personnes
pas plus à compter de dimanche donc
après le 24 et le 25 à noël deux bulles
six personnes ou de bulles ça c'est ce
qu'on a changé on prend un tour de vis
supplémentaire
qu'il soit intéressant de thomas gerber
qui a dit parce qu'on sait que les
cinémas sas avait été annoncée la
semaine dernière les cinémas sont fermés
les bas sont fermés les restaurants
c'est que de 17 heures à 22 heures
thomas demandé mais ce qu'on devrait pas
c'est et obligé la vaccination
poursuit pour les récalcitrants pour
ceux qui veulent pas se faire vacciner
et donc donner un peu plus de liberté je
souligne que ça ne se fait pas il ya des
projets en allemagne pour le mois de
février mais dans un pays du tadjikistan
qui le fais ma passion n'a pas vraiment
d'autre sébastien le milieu sera quand
même 10 est pas exclu la vexation
obligatoire mais donc un vrai pas fermé
la porte mais on s'est pas à court terme
quelque chose qui est envisagée avec
l'urgence sanitaire le gouvernement a le
pouvoir de le faire mais c'est très
délicat d'imposer la vaccination
obligatoire et reste quand même une
certaine liberté pour ceux qui veulent
pas être le maxxi n'est j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya plus ouvert la
porte sur de nouvelles restrictions qui
pourraient faire en sorte que les non
vaccinés plus de difficultés à accéder à
certaines certains endroits peut-être au
québec donc plus de privilèges pour les
vacciner moi un privilège pour les non
vaccinés c'est peut-être plus aux verts
qu'aux bons michel pour ce qui est des
annonces on revient l'annnonce du sis
sinon qu'est-ce qui vous a frappé et ça
m'a frappée parce que je suis raide
directement visibles rétraction qui 60
ans une seule sur le panel mais je
triple vacciner puisque ça va aller mais
[Musique]
comme
organisation
vous rendez vous
avec l'un des bouts mais en une
demi-heure tous souhaitaient pas y
compris l'accueil de 15 minutes
d'attentes remarquable inquiété mais je
remarque aussi que
le gouvernement insiste encore pour dire
les non vaccinés sont à risque et ils
prennent 50 % des hôpitaux si on n'avait
pas ça on ne répond le problème qu'on
risque d'avoir de surcharge du système
la vaccination obligatoire est
probablement pour quelque chose que le
gouvernement considère sérieusement ne
serait ce que parce qu'il n'y a pas un
pays dit démocratique qui ne leur fait
savoir faire travailler plus de mongkok
médecins ça c'est sûr
mais mais il reste que le travail de
convaincre ces gens là et on est très
bien rendue au noyau dur là qui veulent
rien savoir d'une vaccination nous on va
essayer encore mais c'est pas mal
certain que ça ne fonctionnera pas donc
on risque d'avoir un problème les
hôpitaux à cause de ce qu'est ce qui
vous a frappé dans cette conférence de
presse
ce qui me frappe c'est qu'effectivement
elle ya quand même un peu d'espoir ce
sens que on dit qu'il ya une marge de
manoeuvre et demain ça va se faire aussi
au coût de délestage ne faut pas
l'oublier mais mais on voit tout de même
que le système craque leur demande à la
population de de façon propre
d'applis et c'est son propre traçage et
d'appeler les gens et qu'ils auraient pu
compte qu'ils auraient pu contaminer on
demande aux gens de ne pas aller se
faire tester en clinique dans certaines
circonstances parce qu'on dit bon mais
on manque de capacité on demande aux
gens de ne pas utiliser les tests
rapides pour dans certaines
circonstances parce qu'on veut déménager
parce qu'on en manque c'est ce et c'est
ce que je sais ce que je peux le dire
qu'on semble être un peu à court de
ressources
sur l'été frappé de sébastien je pense
qu'on a nos parlent ils ont souligné à
plusieurs reprises mais monsieur legault
dit ça va bien avec ottawa il nous en
promettent beaucoup meilleures ventes on
on reconnaît parce que hier et
avant-hier ceux qui ont essayé de l'en
chercher l'information n'est pas évident
et le plan de match c'était que à peu
près tous les québécois puissent en
avoir un kit une boîte chez eux pour
pour les fêtes pour se tester on a
l'impression qu'on sera pas grave de la
tête parce qu'en effet ça va pas assez
vite le rythme